[Applause]
keep your shirts
on lady put your bra back on all right
it's Friday and I should button
up too much skin let's welcome tonight's
guests he wrote up in the air and now
he's in our chair novelist and literary
critic Walter
cerr he used to write for Rolling Stone
but everyone deserves a second chance
Editor in Chief of Racket news m
taii she's an independent voter and she
knows CTT loader host of Kennedy Saves
the World podcast
Kennedy and the only thing bigger than
his body is his
brain New York Times bestselling author
comedian and former NWA world champion
Tyrant wow I'm already tired
but before we get to some new stories
let's do
this Greg's leftovers
yeah yeah it's leftovers it's where I
read the jokes we didn't use this week
and as always it's my first time reading
these so if they suck we'll strap Joe
macki to a table and have lizo sit on
his
chest wow here we go doctors doctors at
a hospital in Ohio have been accused of
propping up a dead patient in order to
make her appear appear alive for
visitors
G I wonder where they got that
idea speaking of President B's German
Shepherd Commander was seen biting
another White House staffer when asked
if they were going to put Commander down
a White House staffer asked which
one how dare you laugh at that he's our
president major US Airlines have
discovered that some of their jet
engines have been maintained using parts
that had forged safety certificates in
response Executives at Spirit Air said
wait you guys do
maintenance weird it's called Spirit on
Wednesday Hooters celebrated the
company's 40th
birthday it's a great meal yes it is but
also 40 Years of men lying to their
wives that they go there for the
wings a 104 year-old woman took a record
setting jump
as the oldest person to ever go
skydiving she landed in 12 minutes but
her boobs landed in
10 I hope she doesn't watch but she is
in our
demo keep taking that relief Factor
study found that some animals reduce
conflict in the Wild by having gay sex
yeah yeah this EXP explains why I've
been spotting all those penguins at
brunch uh if you lived in New York you'd
understand an obese social media
influencers demanding hotels widen their
hallways to accommodate Travelers of her
size in her response Expedia suggested
she stay at a motel
12 Democrat Junior Squad member Jamal
Bowman pulled a fire alarm postponing a
key Congressional vote the former New
York City school teacher said the
doorway confused him because he's
[Laughter]
stupid sometimes you don't even have to
write the
joke a YouTube prankster survived being
shot by a delivery man that he was
harassing the shooter was found not
guilty of malicious wounding but guilty
of unlawfully discharging a firearm or
as they call it in Hollywood no
biggie oh a yeah yeah yeah who cares DHS
secretary mius announced the government
will build a wall on the southern border
despite one despite once saying that
walls don't work but President Biden
clarified walls do work it's stairs that
remain a
problem there you
go a Tech conference that excluded men
was overwhelmed by dudes who lied about
their gender identity what do they think
this is a woman's
prison Mattel's new Stevie Nicks Barbie
doll quickly sold out comes with a
tambourine black boots and a cocaine
addiction Starbucks is closing seven
downtown San Francisco locations the
good news you can still get a human turd
on the street in venti or
Grande
disgusting yeah you love those poop
jokes yeah new survey finds that
Americans consider Freddy Krueger one of
the top horror icons which is impressive
considering the stiff competition a not
funny poor
lady a 76-year-old Florida woman fled
the scene of a hit and run driving with
the other driver draped over the hood of
her SUV for two
miles I know police easily identified
the car as the whole time she left her
turn signal
on Kevin spacy says he was rushed to the
hospital fearing a heart attack after
his left arm went numb after me his male
doctor Kevin said the numbness had
spread to his
penis it's unfair he's innocent Disney
reportedly plans to make the new Bambi
liveaction less traumatic for kids this
time instead of getting shot Bambi's
mother will just move to
[Applause]
Chicago all right applauding the death
of a deer finally finally Congressman
hem qu Hemi Hemi Henry quailer was
carjacked in Washington DC this week
other members of Congress said they were
glad he was okay then went back to
banging
hookers all right to the
news do young men need a class in order
to make a pass on a recent podcast NYU
Professor Scott Galloway says young men
should learn so-called mating Dynamics
amid the rise of artificial in ENT sex
box also known as Mark
Zuckerberg a course on mating I think I
have the perfect teacher in
mind let's watch I think every every
teenager in in high school should have a
course as part of Health on mating
Dynamics where they teach especially
young men that approaching a woman and
expressing romatic interest while making
her feel safe is a skill and there's
nothing wrong with that and that the end
game a relationship a partner a romantic
uh partner is one of the keys to a happy
life also a key to a happy life two hit
shows six bestsellers in the face of
God oh stop it and I didn't write that
all right okay I'll take it I'll take it
but as fewer dudes risk dating rejection
in the real world he offered this dire
warning I think that AI in combination
with sex bots is going to create an
industry where Men start having
relationships with algorithms and
Dolls sounds awesome what do I sign up
but start having relationships with
algorithms and Dolls I know apparently
hasn't heard of hookers but the
professor suggested several ways young
men can improve themselves which include
putting on a clean shirt showering more
often and hitting the gym once in a
while well that eliminates Kid
Rock hey is not doing the show but come
on how about a class for women too maybe
stop expecting men to be rich funny and
over
5'5 I feel bad for the people who meet
none of those
standards but really the professor's not
wrong in this day and age boys are more
likely to bond with a laptop over a lady
there's pornography video games and a
glut of prescription meds which together
dull the natural urges and that prevents
them from dating meeting a soulmate
getting married having kids and then
losing their house in a gut-wrenching
soul sucking divorce then you end up
dying alone in a studio apartment above
a bail bondsman drowning in cheap booze
and regret we call that the
Berman all
[Applause]
right there's some truth to this Walter
right I mean kids today we used to have
to like look for our pornography in
parks that come out the way I wanted it
to but it's true like some teens would
hide it in a hedge and then you'd come
around later and find it it was like it
was like the it was like a rural Library
treasure hunt yeah treasure hunt see I I
I disagree and I think this is bad
advice yeah um men you know as far as
sex bots and pornography go men after a
million years of hunting elk and
bringing them home to their wives and
the wife saying that's a pretty small
elk um
have finally got the world exactly the
way they want it uh and uh this guy is
saying it's immature um the fact is that
the way to get women also is not to make
them feel safe I used to try to do that
yeah um and they would leave my table
and go over to the guy in the leather
jacket who made them feel excited yeah
um so he's not going to he's not going
to Foster any relationships with this
sort of Soft Cell clean shirt make them
seal safe advice yeah if guys want to
know how to get women they should listen
to Mick Jagger not NYU
Professor that is true now Matt first
time on the show before I ask you a
question I want to clear the air back
maybe 15 years ago or so I wasn't fair
to you I used I feel bad so I want to
make it up to to you with
this I'm so
sorry
[Music]
m
I've made fun of you for years I feel
ashame I'm so
Sor
I but I
[Music]
seen I'm so
sorry oh
my it's true oh please believe
me I'm sorry
yes is that David
Bowie that was that was Jean that was
very David bowiesque there Jean and he
did never heard that song before Matt I
hope you're touched and in a good way
very touched yes so back to this topic
which now seems like a million years ago
uh do you think that that was good
advice
well I think if you don't know how to
talk to girls because you're too
online talking to a robot probably isn't
going to fix the problem yes um you know
and I kind of second Walter's thoughts
on this if you if you want to learn how
to talk to girls
probably you know getting instruction
from a guy spends his whole day in front
of a screen is not the way to go just
send all these people to Italy for like
3 hours right that's true they'll come
back and they'll actually know something
an exchange dating program where they
just send you to places where men still
talk to women and just like talk to
women constantly exactly it this should
be taught by construction
workers and mcjagger and MC Jagger oh my
God MC Jagger as a construction worker
yes I need a moment you know Kennedy uh
he said that also that women have an
issue with dating shorter men which I
have never noticed
so what do you say I I don't like it
when women solely the name of other
women by demanding that men are rich or
of a certain height before they meet
them and before they determine whether
or not they have anything in common or
this Alchemy which is so incredibly
important and I think that's what the
professor is trying to get at as human
beings we're tactile we like to feel
things and smell things and we are
removed from that process when our
entire lives are are digital but he's
also in New York City if you go to
different parts of the country people
are still outside people are swimming in
rivers and people are snowboarding and
if those are the kind of people you want
you have to put yourself in those
situations and take yourself out of a
city but Matt's absolutely right about
Italy like in Italy men will make love
to you with their eyes and in Germany
they just stare at you like dudes stare
at you and it's like I don't know if
you're a serial killer or you're super
into me but now I want to see your
schnitzel
so
but there there's something about the
confidence of the approach that that
some men are missing and then a lot of
young women dress like and that
makes me sad too yeah the thing is it's
a challenge for a young men because the
first question you have to ask is I just
want to make sure do you have a
penis I've asked that I thought that
would land
harder so did
she why do penis jokes if they're not
funny yeah yeah they're just being a
about
it
ah Tyrus you are uh okay here's I'm a
conqueror yes conquered I'm not afraid
to say it but the thing is my dance card
is full I'm not I'm proud of that how
many kids you got I
got for tax purposes I have
four and they're all different
ethnicities you know what I'm saying so
I was winning in All Phases of the woman
gang so I'm proud of that did you have a
was it a challenge for you in terms of
now that we talk about safety and
safeness that like would you would
approach a woman and you're
68 listen
geld here's the problem here's the
problem let me break it down for you we
don't need a class for men to learn how
to be men we have to go out and fail you
have to you don't need people coming to
school and telling you at 7 whether you
want what rainbow or whatever you want
to be and you can identify as this and
that you have to go out in The Recess
yard and get chased and threatened by
girls it's part of the process you have
to fail
and you go to first dance and you're
terrified and you walk up to a girl and
like would you like to dance and she's
going to say no and her girlfriends are
going to see her say no and they're
going to laugh at you and it's going to
hurt okay it's going to hurt it's hurt
and your boys your boys are going to be
like damn and you're going to get
through it and you're going to be fine
you're going to keep asking then you're
going to get clever and you're going to
say hey would you like to dance she'll
say no I didn't say dance so you look
fat in your pants what' you say to me I
didn't say nothing I didn't say nothing
did you say something now your boy are
laughing yeah and she's not going to
dance with you she's going to go back
and tell the girls you know what he said
to me and and one of the girls why
they're saying that's going to do
this then she comes ask you to dance you
have to go out there you got to be you
got to be a hunter you got to take your
you got to build it there you go and
then eventually you can have babies from
all over the
[Laughter]
world
but what you've just described is the
reason we have sex bots um no not to
have to go through that yeah but that's
how you you you need Stripes you got to
get we got to get Stripes we've got to
failure is beautiful because you build
confidence because then when it when you
get hit in the mouth you're good you've
been hit before yeah but you know what's
going to happen once a AI or robots get
uh become conscious then they're going
to be able to reject you and imagine
getting turned down by a robot something
you bought it already happens your card
was not accepted sir you have another
form of faming
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else